what's your process six months before
production three months
two months a week um it varies the
process of
six months three months two minutes etc
it varies but
i would say here's pre-production right
for a producer that's like the first
big milestone starting pre-production
because you're working way before
you're the only one but you're working
before pre-production because the
official
pre-production starting you have a team
involved so there's a lot more money
involved
for pre-production but before that you
are focusing on possible issues
before you bring other people on and
those possible issues first of course
starts with a script
um it starts with where the money is
coming from what their expectations are
what they like and don't like how they
want to be communicated to
it's establishing what your identity is
as a project
what kind of people are going to bring
that together just kind of game planning
on
where you're about to go is going to be
putting pieces together but you can't
put pieces together yet until you know
the box that you're going to be putting
them in so kind of establishing that box
if that's the
way they put it that's what's happening
six months out
you're establishing a box and that might
take a year
instead of six months but you you have
to do it way before you're actually
doing the work
way before you're bringing people in
that you're going to lead and ask to do
a job
you need to have a boxer to fit into and
it's hard to do it because
as producers we're not the people that
actually are going to do it
so it's hard to say this is the box now
do your thing in that box
unless you have a true vision of where
you're going
so first things first six months out you
should already have a vision but if you
don't
establish it hardcore because if you're
going to hire directors specifically
some projects you know the director is
already on but if you're going to hire
someone to then
lead the way in this beautiful creative
he needs to know
where you're going because then he can
say got it
here's my creative i'm going to fit it
into that and we're going to go in the
same direction
because producers and directors oh my
goodness they can
or they can do this and when they do
this beautiful things happen
and usually what i see i take the onus
of that the producer has to establish a
culture
a direction how we're going to do this
has to and it's not saying this is the
way it's going to go saying hey this is
what i'm thinking
this is what i see and see if that
person can bond with that
and then be themselves within those
confines because
as producers we're the only people that
has a power over that person and we
gotta be really mindful of that power
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be
concerned like
putting your power in there because you
don't like what they're doing you know
it's like oh well
they're creative just doesn't make sense
to me today doesn't matter that's their
creative you are hired them that's your
fault
so understanding though before you start
having them work as the leader of that
that set you need to make sure they know
what you expect
where you're at what the the stakes are
even like directors they come in they're
not supposed to think about money
they first have to feel free to create
and feel the free to go
grab 12 wigs for this one actor no you
know
or whatever it is like we we need a
prosthetic do you you know
but understanding the stakes the limits
the boundaries and then telling them
run wild in that space but you know kind
of working on that relationship too
and the reason i say that a lot of
people think of that as
counterproductive
but it's so productive because that
relationship is going to determine
everything else that's like the two
people that make the film happen
and of course there's money and all
these things but the producer and the
director
if their relationship can work it's
boundless with
what the film can do because now we have
an actual culture we have an actual
direction we have an actual thing and
those things don't have to war
they do war in some ways because you're
constantly like oh we don't have enough
money for that or whatever it is
so you have to tell them know about some
things but then if you're already
established kind of a way to move
that can work so much better um and then
three months out
it's pretty much the same thing but
you're kind of like now team building a
little bit
um you might already have like your
cinematographer on
it might be a director that always works
with a particular cinematographer and
that's
great but just make sure you connect
with that cinematographer as well
because the director and cinematographer
are the first people to argue
the first so if they're buddies and
they're the guys that like
man i love their bond you need to be in
that bond you need to take them out to
dinner you need to go hang out with
cinematographer
without the director take him to lunch
by himself separate them for two seconds
and then bring him back together the
reason being
again your game planning six months from
then three months from then they might
have a little spat
and now here you are you've connected
this wonderful director you know him
and you don't know a thing about the
cinematographer how can you solve
the conflict and you know nothing about
this person so this woman that comes in
to
film your project and direct the camera
this beautiful cinematographer comes in
and her director is rubbing her the
wrong way
does she come to you is she able to talk
to you about it or does it just
poison your set because you didn't even
think oh i need to reach out to her too
because i see that another mistake
producers make they don't establish
relationships with all the heads of
departments they're
kind of just like with the director and
then it's like oh yeah
no like get in there like have some
moments with each of them
know something about them you don't have
to like take them to lunch all of them
separately but do enough and the
cinematographer i think would be if
you're going to focus
with someone else focusing with them
because a lot of times
these cinematographers are very
technical i grew up with around a very
technical brother they're not
necessarily going to tell you how they
feel unless they feel safe
it's certain people that like safe or
not they're like listen here this is not
okay
but cinematographers usually have a
certain i mean they don't all
they're not all the same but usually
they have a certain attraction to
technical things
so that's a lot of things the way that
brain works is normally not like
blah blah blah blah blah so i think it's
really important to
connect with the hesitant department but
especially the cinematographer
and even if it's not for anything else
you're like this is a waste of time i
have so much to
connect with them because later down the
line you're really solving a problem
that you're going to be able to navigate
well and with
actual knowledge that you can thwart it
and get rid of it
and bring those guys back together and i
say guys because i'm you know i say guys
for guys girls whatever
bring them back together in a way that
is good for everyone because it's almost
like when cinematographers and directors
have a moment it's like mommy and daddy
are arguing like you know
for the cast and crew like this is
uncomfortable so you got all these
people
under these two people and they're all
taking directional cinematographers
talking to these gaffers and these grips
and whatever
the director's talking to the actors and
this and the upm and ad like all this
stuff is happening from their hands
make sure you know these these people
are with you
you're with them you've already learned
a little bit about them you've hung out
with them a bit
so when something happens if something's
happening down here on the lower levels
um above the line or below the line you
know all right let me
i know how to handle this with my heads
because you can't lead
everybody but you can lead leaders so
make sure you're hiring people that are
leaders in your head positions not just
the person that's best
the key makeup artist or the key here
she might not be the best
make up her hair but she can lead a team
she can communicate to the a.d
she knows how to verbalize her issues
and hear something and not be offended
but also just make a quick change
not be destroyed under pressure but the
girl that
or the guy that is like the one that's
working on the main actor
they're the best in the room but they
can't work with anybody they can't leave
anybody so they have their little their
little task but connect with that key
connect with that person and when hiring
them make sure that you know
that person can handle the pressure of
their job not just the work itself the
pressure
of it so i think that's another thing
when you're hiring that crew
um ask questions that are beyond just
technical or
straight to their particular little
world
ask them about them and you'll be
surprised people will talk about
themselves and you're like oh
i don't think this is going to work
or hey you know what i'm going to bring
on as a makeup artist i'm actually
having someone else
going to be the key but i want you to
soar and do a great job and you know
whatever you're going to do so yeah i
think it's
really making sure you're establishing
culture establishing that box but really
digging in to your heads like your
department heads really need to be
established not only and they
are clear on the vision they're clear on
the the task at hand and they feel
motivated and all those things they
understand the project
but also that they understand they're
about to lead a team
and this is the way i lead i let them
know i don't want any egos on my set i
don't want any
let me tell you about yourself type
stuff like no this is the way we this is
where i lead this is why i'm going to
treat you
this is my expectation for you going
forward somebody messes up have some
grace with them
communicate that to them if you need
assistance and you need backup
use me as the bad guy you don't have to
be it i tell them that all the time
let me be the bad guy you can even say
so rachel's putting the pressure on me
like it's fine i'm fine being that
person in that way the bad guy in that
way
but it's like so often where
we're only thinking in pre-production or
going into pre-production we're thinking
of
i got this in my schedule i got my
checklist there's so many checklists
online now that you can like oh
check check check add to that checklist
people skills
check i understand my head's a
department check
i understand their motivations check add
those things because those are the
things that
something can fall through and just not
go well it's not just because you didn't
have enough funding
it's not just because your lead actor
was in an accident that happened to a
friend of mine just recently it's those
those moments where the team just
something happens
and now they're not able to create the
best or they're just not being able to
work together at all
so i think we had a youtube comment from
someone
that said like and make sure that it's
not just a team of people
that all know each other and then you're
the new person because if
somebody turns and there's like cancer
and then
somehow that's then now you're the odd
person out you know what you're saying
i said um that's so true uh familiarity
is not the
goal it's um do you fit into the culture
of the set
so when you hire people like you know
especially hiring directors like well
these are my guys
you need to meet those guys before you
say yes meet them and then i would say
integrate integrate integrate because if
that these particular people
are working together and they're
they have a certain way of doing things
and
that's great but they've maybe worked on
it
on a commercial or a short they haven't
been on now this is a group of people
that did five features together
what do you need me for what's your
goals what like let me see if i actually
do
actually work with this like is this who
i want on my
set is this how oh i want to present to
this executive producer or whatever
um but when you see that a lot of times
it's because they worked shallow enough
to where they stayed
in a sound peaceful place for just long
enough to do this movie you're about to
hire them for
and when they get to the stress of this
feature it's going to dissipate and i
was on i was a d on a project that it
happened on
i was a d and usually ads are like kind
of like the the odd man out because you
got to be
like the yelling the yelling director
right so you kind of be
you're not part of the crew that work
together you're just there just you know
do your job and these guys you
thought they were like brothers when
they were hired guys and girls are just
guys you know brothers sisters
um and by i would say
week three of the production the
extreme of the emotion in that room
because something went wrong
was only because they knew each other
like brothers and there was no one else
there to balance it out
so it fell apart the project i only
think was finished i had to leave i had
to go to another project but
it was because they they're coming into
things and it's not to say you can't do
it
it's just they're coming in with so much
history without ever maybe dealing with
you got to find out what's the level of
intimacy
not familiarity great they have fun
together they have beers together
they go to skate parks together i don't
know but
what's the intimacy level of this group
have they offended each other before
and i can ask them that when hiring them
like so have you ever gotten an argument
with each other before or
did you ever disagree with the director
you're talking to have you ever
disagreed with that person or whatever
yeah yeah yeah he did such-and-such ask
them probe they're
like no we're great we never argue come
on these guys
are working together on a film
something's going to come up that they
disagree with
and i need to know you can handle that
if you haven't handled it yet no worries
i need to know though how you guys
handle conflict before
i say yes to them being on the set so i
think a lot of times people
like oh great that that's higher was
super easy i got this one guy and got
all these other guys and now i'm done
hold up timeout there might be something
here that you're
you're going to have to dig into to make
sure you're going to take all of them
and if it's like all or nothing that's
fine too because i like group say like
yeah it's all of us or nothing
fine but just find out who's the weakest
link who's the negative one who's a
pessimist who's a realist who's the
optimist
and you see if those things work
together so like the optimist is the guy
that's like
the leader of the group you're gonna do
a lot better but the guy that's the lead
of the group
is the pessimist and the realist is you
know just kind of in the middle and the
optimus is getting on that pessimist
nerves and the realist is trying to
balance them out and then
it just it's going to explode and you're
going to have to fix it as a producer
how can you fix that with people that
know each other and they don't know you
it's hard so it's not overcomeable
it's not insurmountable it is
overcomeable but
you need to be aware of it and make sure
that you're really
not like i said taking it like oh yes
this was easy
easy hire really dig in and it's another
i think it's another level of hiring
when you hire people that know each
other so well
you